if you if you're doing what you love to
do
you have the most chance of a lot of
success
if you do things because the money is
good
that's a very bad reason
you're not doing not work well
if you want to
enjoy
the work you're doing
you have to focus on doing work
that you are passionate about that you
love
so
a lot of people for example
they want to go to iit
they want to go to computer science
they want to
become software engineers
but then when you ask them why all of
those things
it's because they want to make a lot of
money
that's the wrong reason
to do that
it's okay to do those things if you love
software development and software
engineering and all that
if your passion is painting
or your passion is poetry
you should pursue those passions
so the most important thing is if you
want to do things well in life
you have to do what you enjoy doing so
this is a difficult thing for most
people because
when you are young
it's hard to know
what you like
and the reason it's hard to know what
you like is because you have not had
that much experience
to try many things
but you have some indications right so
if let's say you're studying physics
chemistry math
one of those subjects may be much more
interesting to you than the other
subject
right
so that gives you some indicator that
you are more interested
in physics than chemistry
so maybe you focus
something which is related to physics or
within physics you are very fascinated
with
celestial bodies and astronomy and
you know space and all that so then you
know
i want to maybe go into aeronautics or
something like that right so
you try to ask yourself what do i really
enjoy
don't ask yourself
what will give me a lot of money
ask yourself what you will enjoy
and if you do what you enjoy
you will
have the most success
if you do what
other people tell you to do
or you do it because your friends are
doing it
then that's the wrong reason
so
every day
when i uh wake up
i always focus on doing things that i
enjoy doing
i don't care about what people will
think about it also like today
december 24th
i'm here with you
i could be in hawaii
on a beach
drinking a nice drink
and just enjoying
but that is useless
this is more fun
so i decided i want to come here
and not go to some beach
okay
i can go and do some touring or some
tourism all useless
it's more fun
to talk to dakshina scholars
so
i tried a lot of things and i find that
having
having
interaction
which dakshna scholars
is one of the good things to do it's a
lot of fun to do that
and uh and in fact i was i i always
liked coming to kerala so much
how many of you love kerala
raise your hand
how many of you love the red rice of
kerala
only one two three
four five
okay
acquired taste
take some time to like it
um so
i was actually thinking normally i see
a batch
once
because i have to meet so many batches
but i was thinking because
kotayam and kerala is so much fun i
should come every year
because it's just fun
so maybe next year i'll come back again
okay
and maybe again on december 24th
when the whole school is gone just us
and by then you'll think of some new
questions to ask me
so
you have to focus on doing things that
you love to do
if you if you're doing what you love to
do
you have the most chance of a lot of
success
if you do things because the money is
good
that's a very bad reason
you're not doing not work well here's
the punch line
what i'm seeing and so many of you are
answering on this is
people are crippled when they have to
create original content but when you
actually understand that you and your
life are the unique piece of creative it
changes everything is everybody
interesting no i mean the answer is no
not to the macro meaning not everybody
is destined to become a social media
reality star
but so many people are destined that
will never start so many people like
look you don't have to be the
kardashians right you can be some
version of it here's what i do know
there are a thousand people watching
this right now that if they started
making snapchat stories instagram
stories youtube videos facebook videos
and post three or four times a day
documenting what they're doing eating
this lunch taking my kid to school this
is who my uncle is this is my sister
this is what i'm into this is soccer
practice that they started documenting
instead of like oh let me make a video
about like how the sun comes up or like
instead of creating something you just
document your actual life my biggest
belief is so many of you should be
documenting your journey of becoming an
intern of becoming
moving from college to the real life
going through your divorce starting your
new business if you document your truth
my belief is that there is a stunning
amount 1 000 of you watching right now
who could make as much money
and that might be 80 000 and that might
be 380 000 you can make as much money
documenting your life through all these
channels
and making monetization through ads
affiliates sponsorship deals speaking
engagements books and all the other
ancillary things that happened you could
make as much money being you
as much money being tyler babin as
getting paid at vaynermedia being tyler
babin in the production team like i just
believe that truth now that might not be
for everybody but it is for a lot of you
and unlike tyler babin thank god most of
you don't like your job he likes it so
that's what would prevent him and you
may love your job and that will prevent
you but if you were sitting here today
in 2017 and you are watching this piece
of content which means you listen to my
themes and care about my stuff and
you're in this ethos you just start
dialing well then you need to understand
what documenting versus creating is not
everybody's going to create that show
you know it's a lot easier to make a
documentary than cheers if you
understand the power of the current
platforms and things that nature it's
not that documenting is so easy either
but just telling your real life on a
daily basis super interesting to me and
something all of you should at least try
what's the cost a couple leisure hours
on [ __ ]
you